[Music]
education is changing many teachers now
show videos in their classrooms and
students use them for their homework or
to prepare for exams this development is
great when technology helps students to
improve their learning but it can be a
disadvantage for those who have to
consume endless hours of boring or
misleading information at sprouts we
imagine a world where teachers and
students have free access to a wide
range of interesting materials that were
developed following high academic
standards we are on a mission to explain
complicated ideas with short cartoon
animations that inspire teachers and
students to do projects and dive deeper
into the subject sprouts videos are
published under the Creative Commons
license that means our videos are free
and anyone can download edit and play
them for personal use and public schools
governments and nonprofit organizations
can also use them for training online
courses or designing new curriculums
today over a million students watch
sprouts videos every month and because
our videos are presented as cartoons
students from all around the world can
relate as a result volunteers have
translated our videos into Chinese
French Hebrew and many many other
languages
it all began in 2014 at the time Jonah's
Koblin was working in the corner office
of a successful marketing company
thinking about how to follow his true
calling improving education for
disadvantaged children a kilometre down
the road Marc Schwinn had just started
minute videos with a mission to
democratize video production for
education when the two met they became
friends and started working together
Marc brought along his team including
Pascal gonnelli who draws all of our
cartoons Jonah's convinced his sister
Selina beador
to leave her teaching position and join
as head of content today we are a
committed team of independent teachers
academics creators and producers who are
working remote
from around the globe trying to help
revolutionize learning it is our aim to
make a difference and you can too if you
have deep insights into academic topics
and want to help us explain complicated
ideas and simple language please contact
us at sprouts schools comm to help us
stay independent and support our work
you can join our patrons and contribute
just visit patreon.com slash sprouts
even one dollar can make a difference